mein Humor ist komplett verloren
das was ich witzig finde und worüber ich
lache Teilen aus meinem ganzen
Freundeskreis vielleicht zwei Personen
ja okay ich habe auch nur zwei Freunde
also eine kurze Info bevor dieses Video
hier losgeht wenn euer Humor vernünftig
ist und ihr einen klassischer Mensch
seit der ganz normale Dinge und Witz
lustig findet dann werdet ihr heute
einmal lachen
deswegen schaltet am besten aus dieses
Video ist eigentlich nur für mich
gemacht weil mein Humor so verdreht ist
dass ich sowas extrem lustig finde how
Italian peoples lieb
[Musik]
Graps ist lights of pizza
eine Freundin hat mir diese memes
rausgesucht weil ihr Humor ist genauso
verdreht wie meiner Namen und meinte nur
so Luca hier schau dir den Ordner an
am Arsch alles am Arsch the Weasleys in
the movies the Weasleys in the books
Fred Ginny George
sind alles glaube ich memes
die genau
das sind was sie sind how
it started vs how it's going
ey ich kann komplett ab ne es ist
peinlich für mich dieses Video hier
hochzuladen letzte nice ham you got
there it would be a shame of someone es
in front and I behind it
[Musik]
wie dumm sind diese jokes bitte so I
believe I made myself clear
ich glaube alle werden meinen Kanal
deabonnieren nach diesem Video hier when
you move your legs forward in order to
alive at the death
h es ist für mich so peinlich dass ich
darüber lache aber es ist für mich noch
peinlicher das hier hochzuladen ich
denke gerade jede Sekunde darüber nach
dieses Video hier nicht hochzuladen nie
kenoided home Mum das food and
McDonald's
niemand der sich somit also no way
[Musik]
so true ist einfach wahr
es ist wirklich Grinch this is go
oh ich kann
[Musik]
es ist doch wirklich
das wird niemand verstehen niemand von
euch wird diesen dummen Humor mit mir
teilen das ist so traurig ich fühle mich
gerade no joke wie immer während unseren
Podcast Aufnahmen wo ich immer jokes
Reise und niemand im ganzen Studio
versteht es
oder ich bin wirklich einfach nicht
witzig old but gold
ich menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
Brief look back at nineteen seventy five
Show Wii und
entweder muss man extrem schlau sein um
diese ganzen memes zu verstehen
oder man muss extrem dumm sein weil ich
glaube normale Menschen checken gar
nichts gerade Gandalf in the films
Gandalf Winter ja okay ist genau das
gleiche bei den Weasleys da Kacke ich
jetzt nicht ab teacher okay Claas today
we are going to kill Jason Kid Name J
es ist so blöd when you have horrible
chest
ich glaube wir leben in der Simulation
Bay kam over me I can am starting for my
Finals okay good luck do your best
die haben einfach so klassische memes
genommen und die einfach komplett auf
die Realität bezogen so dass sie so
richtig unlustig wirken aber so Menschen
wie ich das dann wieder extrem witzig
finden
in Ordnung
sind nämlich an diese eine Podcast Folge
only early 2000 ten kids will remember
the
es ist so traurig
[Musik]
you maybe old but are you this oh
ihr müsst halt immer so überlegen der
Sinn dieser ganzen memes ist halt das
sind diese diese dummens dass die der
Text oben da wird man wirklich denken
okay jetzt kommt wirklich ein meme so
von wegen dem Baby old you this old dann
blenden die irgendwie bei diesen
standardmäßig dann wenn die alte Serie
ein oder ein altes Spielzeug oder so
dann kann man relaten damit aber hier
ist es halt wirklich so ja oder aber das
Old zeigen einfach nur einen alten Mann
und dann weiß man also ich hätte so dumm
wenn man nimmt erklären muss aber
ich versuche mich irgendwie zu
rechtfertigen dass ich hier ab und zu
lache wenn someone ass ist mir good
question
oder
will also wir sind ganz ganz tief
gesunken gerade did you know Elon Musk
is Soul rich thaddy has a lot of me
wirklich ich springe im Arsch when you
see Lemon ICE Lemon
wie viel haben wir noch
ist genau das gleiche wie mit CoD gerade
wenn jetzt almost 128
ich weiß gar nicht mehr was ich sagen
soll
es ist gerade so eine Mischung aus Demut
Angst vor den Reaktionen
selbst hinterfragen
und einen Anruf beim Therapeuten when
you have three Dollar I have the dream
also jetzt gerade bin ich wirklich an
dem Zeitpunkt wo ich jetzt sagen kann
dass ich kein mal mehr lachen werde like
this have nowhere
Girl my parents aren't home guy don't
worry der will come back
Rain be like
ich
es ist
es stinkt nach Durchfall
verywhere photo of the milky way you
from Mars
das ist ein guter joke
den klaue ich für meine insta Story when
you taking a shower
also
diese memes waren lustig
als ich noch nicht wusste um welche
memes es geht
aber da ich jetzt weiß dass jedes Mal
eigentlich gleich ist können wir jetzt
auch zeigen wenn jetzt ein Apple und
dann wird ein Apfel eingeblendet also
ich werde wirklich mit Ansage kein mal
mehr lachen gold
[Musik]
erinnere mich in einer Stunde an goals
Witz Instagram Stories
a boy did this to me
okay meine Damen und Herren ich glaube
dieses Video war absolut nicht lustig
eine Freundin von mir hat gesagt ey Luca
dann Humor ist am Arsch bitte schau dir
diese memes an sie hatten 50 Siemens
oder so geschickt von daher dachte ich
mir ich mache daraus ein Youtube Video
weil wenn jemand das ist mein Humor dann
mache ich wahrscheinlich meistens wenn
es euch dennoch gefallen hat obwohl sehr
der Grinch war sehr peinlich und ich
glaube sehr fremd
alle drei Wörter die ich gerade gesagt
habe bedeuten das gleiche
lasst einen Daumen hoch da wenn es euch
gefallen hat
ich glaube niemand wird nach diesem
Video mein Kanal abonnieren also
eigentlich
könnt ihr es auch lassen